do you guys want to hear more about
Toronto dance salsa so it's not a recent
comment from one of you guys and believe
nation from Alex who said Evan would you
make a video talking about your
experiences Toronto dance salsa or
regular series and so we're curious
email from you guys would you want a
regular series about what I'm doing with
PDF it'd be a little bit harder to
orchestrate and make happen but I'm
curious to figure out is it something
that you guys want to do now I try to
bring up stories that I think are
relevant when i'm doing an espresso or
any of my opinion pieces I always bring
in stories and I think would be relevant
to the topic and often that will include
whatever I'm doing at Toronto dance or
something that's happened in the past
week a couple weeks to try to inject a
little bit more context into how I'm
thinking and what I've learned and how
I'm applying it to my business is what
sounds like that's real different than
this which is a series just focusing on
tds why we're here what we're doing how
we're growing it what the vision is
maybe involving some of my team at TDS
so I'm curious is this something you're
interested in pros and cons let me know
what you think and it's a specific
request that you want to see it is a yes
what's all going to happen is what we
normally do we'll do one test video
it'll be a test video and we'll see you
guys thing and it will take action from
there so is it what you want to see and
then give me specific requests for what
you want to see in that first text video
if that works we might continue if it
doesn't work then we're probably going
to cancel it we'll see so let me know
make it great what would a great first
video look like for you leave it down
the comments below and if you don't like
the idea at all he was a comic store to
see what happens thank you for the
suggestion Alex thank you guys so much
for watching I believe in you hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one where it is much love